say you want to cry by your tears are
dry that was a cut little snippet of uh
of an album I was recommended from some
people a guy named Jason Tebow he's like
skinny scarecrow white guy well I think
he's almost homeless but he's a
podcaster ever you know what he is
mm-hmm you do yeah yeah yeah yeah that
one with them Sam Tripoli yeah yeah he
looks like him Magic Man like if you
were in a forest and he has like little
beads that he sells you like seeds but
rare seeds we were seeds from stardew
valley years be dry though they can be
they crystallized in your eyes and Nick
Youssef you know that Persian guy I know
yeah he's done this podcast right yeah
we did Steve's ESDS
well he'll never do it if you've done
Steve ty Siegel's new album goblins what
is it called freedom freedom freedom
freedom goblin is so good everybody hey
welcome to another episode of tiger
belly I just woke up from a nap because
I just flew in from Houston me tired
there's nine hours constitute as a nap
yeah when you have a slept in three days
ah ah mathematics my friend that's not
sorry it's mathematics my friend oh yeah
mathematics my friend alright and then
we got George Kim's we got Gilbert
Stephanopoulos yeah and we got a grill I
love listen guys um I've been thinking
in my head over and over again
I've been we really being George's set
in my head the whole week oh yeah yeah I
can't stop it it's like I was um I mean
I don't want anyone to get offended I
you know I want to reword it okay okay
it was like I was sexually assaulted mmm
fine yeah by like a celebrity you know
like you know like I was you're me -
that was me - oh god you guys yeah oh
wow I I feel like it's something that I
cannot shake I'm gonna just tell you I
feel like I've a resentment to tell you
right now that that setup made it
impossible that have offend my set and
all that is you you owe me apology thank
you you owe me an apology for making me
witness that so I don't want you to see
I'm sorry
thank you sir that was a great story
alright you know what I really of you
right now you're grounded artistically
all right now you you shut your [ __ ]
mouth wait what does that be he can't
like write jokes right now no just for
like five minutes
okay okay you don't talk for five
minutes are you hairy face [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] George and a scale of 1 to 10 what
would how would you grade yourself put
your fingers up you can't talk I did
like oh my god you know someone rodent
wrote us an email yeah and in regards to
I think we always talk about people who
are delusional yeah and he said that
he's a creative director and he said
that there is a term to describe someone
who thinks they did a lot better than
they actually did and it's called a
dunning-kruger effect effect
dunning-kruger fan a phenomenon
'don't dunning-kruger phenomenon oh a
dunning-kruger effect sorry I was right
what Danny Cruz if you if you change it
again if you change it again I'm never
gonna be able to retain it in my head
tell me if this is what is it an effect
was that okay in the field of psychology
the dunning-kruger effect is a cognitive
bias where in people of low ability
suffer from illis or a superiority
mistakenly assessing their ability is
greater than it is the cognitive bias of
illis or superiority derives from the
inability of low ability persons to
recognize their own ineptitude
it's not mean it is [ __ ] dead all
without the self-awareness of
metacognition low ability people cannot
objectively evaluate their actual
competence or incompetence okay so
there's two types of dunning-kruger
effect
it's that either you hold yourself in
such high esteem or you hold others and
lo you get you have very low regard for
others so like I don't think it's this
ladder I think it's the the first thing
what George that he I think he was ready
to come in hot at five minutes just wait
what was the god damn but I was I was
right now that was read said of the
exact averted I am very fitted by the
low ability statement they kept on
coming up every time you've described
the effect can we keep can we at least
do this can we always do this okay that
I'll give you this you went up there
absolutely not only that not only that
you didn't seem like you weren't
stuttering or oh you tried to get my
head I refined I knew you said think
stop stop let him go don't stop you went
up there and you memorized a bunch of
things and you said those things the way
you plan to say them okay but let's say
I was gonna go see a musician like hey
come check out the singer-songwriter at
you know some coffee shop which I would
never do but anyway like I said I go and
he's up on stage and he's in a clown
outfit and he's juggling and he looks
great he's confident killing it and he's
killing it with the juggling but that's
not what I came to see that's not you
know singing yeah what you were doing up
there was not stand-up comedy it was
some sort of weird spoken word
it was poetry it was no no was a poet it
was a poetry it's not poetry but you
know so I'm gonna give it up to you that
there was a bunch of people there you
went up on stage like you said you would
and you gave us a little horror and I'm
proud of you and I thank you for your
service and let's just leave it at that
you can't tell me that you killed I
wouldn't say I killed per se there's
room for improvement definitely okay and
now that I've had this experience I
think I will improve greatly okay if
there's okay okay it's like this okay
let's say I was a pool man it was empty
pool right and let's just say filling
the pool filling the pool right is being
like a competent stand-up comic okay
okay what you did and I'm not
exaggerating or lying was me taking a
Visine drop and just in the pool a dot
that's the amount here's what I think
here's what I think happened I think I
did okay but then Craig Craig told the
audience I did badly then you went up
and told the audience I did badly you
did afterwards the audience was like
well he did okay I thought but these two
term the George George Kimble yeah it's
a different it's a different one that we
had to create yeah JK a ogk a gka George
Kimble effect
okay I sincere I thought I genuinely
think that you can write you're a great
writer nope chuckles what was up success
up now this is what I wanted to see ya
know it's out right here what I what he
just did right there right was he's now
in for life Gilbert right now did
something that was like so brave
it was so brave and so
Aragorn from Lord of the Rings it was
like whoa dude you're gonna fight those
like you know those Black Riders my
battle with like a torch that's what you
just did and you saved Frodo my god what
you did right there who gave me a lot of
respect you're fired
okay I'm so proud of you George I could
have not done you would have done it I
sweetie
the ten times that I did stand up I
couldn't even get a sentence out I
understand telling you right now and I
promise you I promise you this you would
have done better I wouldn't have
okay well that's that's not right
there's a factual thing everyone
listening to right now all right we're
now on a George Kim Oh like support
group right my name is Bobby George
Kimball addict but the difference with
gka I wouldn't have walked out of there
and said that was pretty good I would
have been like oh my god and I ate it
yeah I can't even he doesn't have that I
ate it yeah you don't have it you don't
have it because I'm gonna tell you this
right now even at your how long you've
been doing it I haven't been doing it
seriously because I dedicate my life to
us and we thank you for your service hmm
he also works for every other person
anyway I mean you're like stretching
yourself then but anyway let me see this
okay if I had to if I had that response
with that many people I literally would
have walked offstage and ask any opener
anyone that I opened for it would have
been precipice I'd be on the precipice
of suicide you're you're healthier than
I am you're healthier there I'm just
telling you me is I just have the
opposite ear effect where if I
everything they do is shitty
everything yeah like this weekend I did
the Houston improv
there was only one show and that's Andy
I walked off a god that was good I was
in the I was in the zone
you know I improvised I was good every
retort was perfect everything was good
and um yeah matter of fact the show
before you went on he came to the green
room when he was in Irvine and he was
like that was the worst show I've ever
done in my life
yeah I cannot I have a good ear and that
you need that if you would have said Wow
I mean I did everything that I said I
would do but that wasn't the response
wasn't what I expected
I'd be like there we go that's what I
want but I don't want to hear oh yeah
that was pretty good I could have done
better but no because this is this isn't
the comedy is not this is the Green
Berets you know you want to be able to
do all the exercises you want to be able
to do all the things so that in combat
you're ready I'm still proud of you
George I'm kind of not you really just
ruined it for me but as a human being as
a human being me and Sandy Dan tour at
the airport today
he's my opener and we're we were like
just we played this game where was I if
someone so died would you cry so I was
rattling off comics names to him he was
like no no yes no no we laugh about it
and he asked if George died would you
cry and I go I think I would but not not
but not but not like I would with kalila
it would be devastating yeah with kalila
it was a bit life altering like I'm you
won't see me for three five years you
know I mean I'm little with you how many
weeks do you grieve for George weeks
okay you would know it would be like I
would have to cancel a bunch of things I
would be devastated yeah would be too
you're just like my work when
work-husband no dye I for sure cry like
a lot yeah I would I would be devastated
you will bother alright feels so bad
about the times that we just roast you
you know yeah on and on yeah yeah you do
a good job that's one compliment there
are very few people that can take what
we give to you I think about this I'm
like is George you know Bobby's like
it's George replaceable and I'm like
nope he's not there is nobody who would
put up this much [ __ ] as you do yeah
with us we're not easy people you're not
and you just you just sit there poker
face and you just take it like a man